Since the Russian invasion began, Ukranians
have shared recipes for making Molotov cocktails
and instructions for driving
abandoned troop carriers.
They’ve used encrypted apps to coordinate
tactics and to ask Russians to stand up to
their government, who in turn have staged
protests in Moscow and other cities.
Though it may end up losing in the battlefield,
Ukraine has been able to show the world the
brutality and folly of the Russian attack,
which is only possible because everyday
citizens have maintained access to the internet.
But maybe not for long: in areas with the heaviest
fighting, internet outages are becoming common,
and since information is power in the
battlefield, there’s a danger that Russia
will find a way to knock the country fully
offline.
Which is why Ukraine’s Minister
of Digital Transformation,
and Vice Prime Minister tweeted a plea to
Elon Musk, “We ask you to provide Ukraine
with Starlink stations and to
address sane Russians to stand.”
“Starlink service is now active in
Ukraine.” Musk tweeted back later that day,
collapsing a regulatory process that can take
months or years into under 280 characters.
Starlink, up and running since
2021, is a global satellite internet provider
owned by Musk’s company SpaceX, which aims
to provide low latency, high speed internet
to areas that are less densely populated and
where fast reliable internet may be lacking.
The first obstacle is that Ukranians can’t
just connect directly to Starlink satellites:
First, they need ground terminals.
“…terminals en route,” was how Musk finished
his tweet, and less than 48 hours later Fedorov
replied with a picture showing a truckload of them
in Ukraine, “Starlink — here. Thanks, Elon Musk”
Those terminals will need to be brought into
cities under siege, and connected to wi-fi,
in turn allowing Ukranians
to connect their devices.
And if terminals lose power, they’ll need
batteries or generators to stay online.
But if the terminals can be
installed and maintained,
Starlink could provide a digital
lifeline to some Ukranians.
Divorcing the online world from
geography and placing it outside
state control is in keeping with
the internet's original promise.
The dream of the internet was one of complete
deterritorialization. Internet was supposed to
mean that it doesn't matter where you live.
You are connected to all of humanity
through this completely transparent network
that where geography is irrelevant. We've seen
how far short of that we have fallen. We've
seen some governments censor the internet
Eli Dourado is a senior research fellow
at the Center for Growth and Opportunity.
I think a great outcome for the internet would
have been for the U.S. to be able to export the
First Amendment to the entire planet, to be
able to say, well, if you're a company
that is based in the U.S. and you're serving the
entire planet and you're subject to U.S. law alone,
then the First Amendment applies everywhere and
nobody can, can stop you from speaking freely.
In reality it hasn't worked out that way. The internet is largely
tied to the politics and geography of earth.
Can Starlink help make good on the internet’s
original promise to be a tool of liberation?
Imagine if Putin had to answer to a populace
with immutable Internet access. Where they
could see the unvarnished reality of war. How
might that change the way a conflict plays out?
One of Starlink’s key innovations is that the
signal can be relayed laterally a number of times,
across country borders, time zones, even oceans,
before beaming back down to a ground station.
That could make it harder for any one country to
censor or track what its citizens access online.
But only if Starlink first turns
on service in those places and then
routes internet traffic through ground
stations in neighboring countries..
Starlink is, uh, you know, of course, a
commercial offering from an American company
that's launching frequently into space
under the outer space treaty, the United
States government is ultimately responsible
for what SpaceX does when it's in space.
While the technology would allow for it, Starlink
may not turn out to serve that grand purpose.
So far, it’s only available in
countries that welcome its presence.
But the technology holds promise .
Satellite internet might one day
offer an uncensored alternative
for people living in hermitkingdoms, behind
great firewalls,or on information islands.
And Everyday Ukranians are putting
truth to power. Coordinating their
defense. Appealing directly to Russian kinship and
a common humanity. Rallying people to their cause.
Showing the devastating cost of war. Starlink
could help them to prevail in that battle.